if you were holding out on your
intention to preorder the Nintendo
switch until you heard what had a
Okajima had to say about it we've got
you sorted as he's now weighed in the
veteran designer told IGN that he
particularly likes the console hybrid
nature noting that the system's
combination of at home and on the go
elements asked similar to the
transferring idea that he came up with
to move data between ps3 and PS Vita he
explained I believe switch is an
extension of that idea the fact you can
play something at home and take it
outside this is the gamers dream this
which is an evolution of that I feel
like cloud technology is what everything
will eventually move to it's further
behind right now than I think where
people thought it would be at this point
but I think it will go there and when
the infrastructure is ready you'll be
able to play everything on every device
anywhere this which is the predecessor
to this desk kijima recently discussed
death stranding at Antioch Sydney where
he explained Stoney has given him
complete creative freedom for more
details on the upcoming game and all the
other things that matter in gaming check
back to games buzz
[Music]